hello everyone today it was a pretty
usual day you know I woke up went to
work went home from work took NATO for a
walk enjoyed some chess and then I saw
this chess game published on chess 24
and I was like whoa it's been quite a
while since it's a chess game like this
it was played actually yesterday in the
24th International Abu Dhabi tournament
it was played between Adam Fazio of
Egypt who is an international investor
and he was playing against the
Grandmaster Barham Micmac Zulu of Iran
and well it's definitely quite a game
Adam is playing white and part on is
black so let's see this game we have E
for g6 and I don't really think this
opening has a name it's considered to be
a modern descent we have d4 Bishop to g7
to Knight to c3 b6 f for now a six-night
2 a 3 B 5 Bishop to d3 Knight to d7 we
have E 5 Bishop to b7 and now Adam
castles we have c5 and our Knight to g5
and here what is preparing some ideas
like f5 so we have Queen to b6 and we
have Bishop to e4 I would have Bishop
captures on e4 Knight captures on e4 and
I'll be 5 kicking that night away from
d5 from e4 Knight to c3 and now e 6 so
okay he stops at 5 that is no longer an
option
so Y plays Bishop to e3 adding
protection to this d4 pawn we have to
capture some p4 Bishop captures on d4
and queen to c6 and here you can see
blacks King is still in the center of
the board and white should definitely
try and take advantage of this and he
tries a 4 which is definitely the
decision trying to break open the
position and well black isn't interested
in this he pushes b4 and here what
doesn't go back he goes forward and he
plays nice to b5 with threats of Knight
d6 check so black captures the knight a
casters on b5 we have taken after some
b5
and I black has a choice he will either
move the Queen or he will capture the
rosewood
of captors anyone black moved the Queen
but let's see what happens if he plays
rook captures on a1a from chapters on a1
and then B captures on c6 we have
broadcasters and big ones and off-key
capture some d7 would check King chapter
77 and now rook captures an b1 and okay
this is a better position for white
black is undeveloped he's not done
material and he does have to deal with
this threat of nice captors on f7 but
this this would be maybe more playable
than the movie he chose so after a
capture some b5 he played a queen to b7
and here white plays Knight rook
captures on a 8 we have Queen captures
on aah and now f5 and here well it's
already very unpleasant for black to
play this position it this isn't well
it's not a loss position for black or
anything like that it's just
uncomfortable
for example if G captures on x5 and
simply Queen to h5 and this is the world
very hard to play for black and if it
captures on s5 then e 6 and the world
white is breaking through so after f5
like decided to play nice captures on e5
and here we have F chapter 76 we have f6
and now Bishop captures on e5 we have F
captors on e5 and now white plays rook
to f7 we have Bishop to f8 and now nice
captures on h7 and there were a lot of
moves possible in this position for
example white could go for Queen to f1
you know to present capture here on f8
he could even play b6 but okay and nice
captures on e7 is definitely a good move
and that's what the whites had decided
to do so we have a nice gastrous on a 7
and I'll be up to c5 check we have King
- h1 and well although this looks pretty
bad for black this is actually an okay
position for black he he is well he's up
a piece of course and he does have this
strong center here and well with a move
like Bishop to e7 it would require a
precise set of moves but he could play
this but he plays Knight to e7 and well
white plays this beautiful
he plays Queen to f1 and the threat of
Queen to f1 is a terrible one he's
threatening rook to f8 check exchanging
the rooks and winning the Queen mah so
what defense this was nice to f5 and all
we have b6 v6 making room for the Queen
on b5 because the Queen to b5 check
would be devastating
so like softest Queen to c6 and now we
have b7 present in b8 with Queen so of
course like has to stop this as well so
he plays Bishop to a7 but the threats of
b7 wasn't just to play be a queen this
pawn will be extremely useful as it
guards the CH Square and this well now
White's next move is definitely a
brilliant one and you're free to find it
for yourself if you would like to import
the video and try and fold this position
to the end so I for those of you who
have I congratulate you it it's quite a
beautiful combination and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the video
Adam played Queen captures on f5 and
this is deadly we have G captures on his
slide and not Knight to f6 check the
only move black has is to placate the d8
and here Weiss plays the beautiful east
7 and again only move available for
black is King to c7 black would very
much enjoy to play King to c8 so this EA
smooth doesn't count with check but
that's why I said that this bone was
extremely useful not just for
threatening Queen but for also guarding
c8 so what King has to go to c7 and here
white plays fall into e8 with Queen and
also checking the black King from the
rock on f7 and in this position black
resigned because even even even if black
would try to continue to play this you
know he does he does have a strong
center here for example if Queen blocks
of course black was the queen is for
King to d6 then simply Queen to e7 is
checkmate only move for black here would
be king to b6 and well if black even try
to play this white win the rook and if
black wanted to try and play this
further because white is present
the v8 with Queen if even if he tries to
protect it with Queen City citizen
simply the Queen again Bishop captures
Queen captures Queen captures an hour
night the Knight to d7 check and well
it's a good thing black resigned when he
did because well it would definitely be
an unpleasant continuation for him so
yeah here we have this is the the
position for black resigned and a
beautiful gain a beautiful game by Adam
fallsy of Egypt and international master
I shouldn't really find any information
on him because he's probably still a
very young player and is making making
you know people in the world hear about
him but no doubt if he continues playing
games like this a lot of people who know
a lot about him very soon so yeah that's
it for this video thank you all for
watching as usual you can check two of
my previous videos here and I'll see you
soon